so welcome back to the iced coffee hour
and I lost
but you did great grandma and we're
really proud of you really I honestly do
yeah seeing you out there in the ring
and seeing you walking up man I I don't
think I've ever been as proud as you I
love you as I have been in our entire
relationship so thanks yeah yeah it was
Nerf it was nerve-wracking like it's uh
it reminds me have you ever seen the
movie Gladiator no you haven't okay so
the movie Gladiator uh Russell Crowe
will wrestle with his character whatever
is like back behind the Gates and
they're sending out people and you just
see these people get mauled and it
reminded me of a scene Like Gladiator
because you would see like we were
backstage we see everybody and they're
all like hyped up and like really
nervous and you'd see them like like
this people were really anxious and you
could tell like uh you know they're
going into this not knowing what to
expect and so I would see them leave and
then you'd watch it on the Monitor and
then it's like a scene from a movie
where it's like you see them walk off on
the Monitor and you look over at the
door and they're walking back and uh I
won't forget like you see them one bag
there's like blood on their nose their
whole eye is red and the one guy was
like walked in I think I think he was
walked in by like two guys like holding
him up walking it sounds like you were
part it sounds like you were part of
Fight Club so we should probably explain
for those of you that don't know what
we're talking about yeah Graham was part
of a boxing match called The Creator
Clash the main card was Ian idubbbz uh
versus Dr Mike and Graham happened to be
fighting Michael Reeves yeah and so he's
talking about all these uh popular
creators that uh that apparently went
out and came back uh like looking like
Warriors you would say huh yeah but the
one guy I'll never forget he was walked
back
um do you know who it was yeah it was
Ryan and I remember him being as nervous
as I was and me looking at Ryan and be
like okay it's cool that he's this
nervous so I'm not the only one but when
he comes back and I see his face just
like lobster red his eye his one eye was
just completely red blood was coming out
of his nose uh his his nose was swollen
up and there are two people like you
know two doctors like doing the eye
stuff and like checking his pulse and
stuff like that and them saying like hey
we recommend that you go to the hospital
and I'm like
we were the same level of nervous and so
right after that I'm like oh did you
just get more nervous yeah because you
see everybody go in there and they're
looking fine and then they come back and
they have injuries every single person
and then I saw uh Minx and and Haley
just going at it I'm like oh man because
I like it's one thing to do a sparring
session with the headgear and like okay
head kind of hurts after you're fine but
this is like the real deal and everyone
is going twice as hard as I would ever
expect so anyway shockingly
I was so nervous leading up to it that
like going up there I was happy I was
actually really excited because it was
going to be done
yeah it was the opposite I never thought
because it was like I got rid of all my
nerves ahead of time and I'm like oh
it's finally gonna be over like I felt
like this huge sense of relief so
walking there like getting up on the on
the thing it was like ah finally like I
don't have to stress about this anymore
and just not and just knowing that it
was almost over was really relieving and
I was like excited for this almost to be
over the other thing is that like
everyone who walked back was like I
don't really remember what happened and
so I kind of went in there thinking well
at least something had I'm not gonna
remember it
and it's true like I really remember
very little very little because you're
so like
it's I guess it's just like the
adrenaline is like and they they say it
they say it that like everyone is
telling me it's oh you know what it was
I was talking to the trainer I was and
he was oh everyone's getting beat up and
I asked him I said why why is no one
like sticking with like what they
learned why are they putting their hands
down why are they doing this and he says
well when you get up on that stage
everything changes and you have to
prepare yourself ahead of time but
there's only so much you could do until
you actually get there and your mind
will sometimes just blank that was very
true and as as much as I went in there
thinking okay just don't put my hands
down back away do this like you know
what to do when you're up there it's
like it's so weird you go into like the
survival mode where you forget
everything it's just like you're not
thinking technique uh do I duck down and
do I like nothing
yeah
you know what I have to say about the
Creator Quest though I was at the press
conference which Jack didn't go to but
uh so I was at the press conference and
I read some of the YouTube comments and
people said it was a little cringy now
I'm not gonna you know I'm gonna agree a
little bit where you know everybody's a
Creator they're trying to be funny
they're trying to be entertaining but
once the fight night came and you see
the first people go at it which were dad
and
Watson was it yeah Dad and Matt Watson
yeah so the the first match is Dad and
Matt Watson and they come out and Dad
just clobbers him within 20 seconds
literally literally we knew that one was
uh we could all see it we saw Dad
backstage and he was so hyped up I mean
he was like doing like just jumping up
and down and like he had there's two
guys next to him were like just like
nuts but I think that's what set the
tone for them yeah like because imagine
if that didn't happen I feel like the
tone would have been a little bit you
know a little bit more relaxed I think
that definitely set a tone for the night
I felt really bad going into I'm like is
that what all of them are gonna be and I
think that they've strategically put all
the other Fighters like right next to
the exit where everyone was leaving the
thing so the fight so they could see
everyone walk out with like the bloody
faces and everything no no we had locker
rooms so like everyone walked back there
and they'd just be pummeled yes I mean
there was a big locker room and so you'd
see see the people you'd be like next to
him be like all right jack good luck 10
minutes you would come back and you're
like a different person would the
opponents be in the same locker room
they were the locker room next so you
couldn't go mingle with the opponents or
anything I mean you could but all of us
kind of you know stuck together do you
think part of your nerves and the way
that you you forgot everything when you
were boxing was caused from like having
a live audience and it being live
streamed yeah it was the pressure of
like whatever I do is going to be seen
by like I don't know how many millions
of people and so that pressure of just
how many people are going to see this
what if I do something
um and then also like what if I get
really hurt
um yeah it changes everything so like I
remember the kind of the kind of the
first round and just thinking uh my only
chance is to get this over with as fast
as possible and like that was I I
thought my only chance but then I
remember finishing the first round and
my entire body was numb and it was a
weird experience but like everything was
pins and needles like you know when your
arm falls asleep yeah my entire body and
doing one round with with that sort of
like Rush with the crowd felt like to me
doing five rounds of sparring like that
last round of sparring I'm like
exhausted but even after that was like
you still like you could stand up and
you're fine this felt like five rounds
plus some and I was like I have to do
this four more times
I I I wasn't prepared for that and then
before I knew it's like the bell rang
again I'm like I'm not ready but you
have to and it and that's where I think
I went down
um you know I think I just there's so
many things I could have done
differently but at the end of the day
when he got that first punch in that one
big right yeah there was one big one
yeah that was the part where I I never
been hit like that before and with
headgear it's you you kind of get like
truffled around a little bit but it's
not like that and I just remember it's
it's a weird like it's not like a crunch
sound but like like
oh yes it's kind of like a crunch but I
remember like I was described to Alex
like you know some of those old cameras
where you like take a picture and the
camera go like that that's how it felt
and went
and uh I needed like probably 30 seconds
to just come to grips with like okay
what's what's going on what because I
never in my life been hit like that
before and so when you when like I
wasn't prepared for that but when you
have no time and you you have to like
instinctually like what do you do well
technically you should put your hands
like this and duck down and there's like
all these strategic things that you
could that's all out the window yeah at
that point it's like deep
I your brain kind of like resets like
restarting a computer that's how it felt
to me it's just like okay it needs to
reboot but by the time it was rebooting
it's like boom you get hit again he said
you need to reboot so I think just you
know and Michael and you know I've done
my best not to watch afterwards because
it's just I just can't watch it but you
know I did see a little bit and uh his
his technicals are really Michael's just
remembered everything and we talked
afterwards and he was saying that after
the first round he was really scared and
uh that really made him realize like oh
crap like if I don't do something right
now I'm gonna lose and I think his
trainer was telling him you have to go
harder you have to like this is your
chant like Graham will win if you don't
make these moves now and he went in so
strategic and I think you could see the
change in this form from the first round
to the second round yes because the
second round he was like he was like a
little ant he was like yep I'm moving
all over the place yeah
um and the other thing I completely
ignored was the trainer was like trying
to drill into me the closer you get to
them the lower you have to be so you
can't stand up if you're like if you're
you've got to crouch down and it makes
you a harder Target
um
forgot that but he was doing that I mean
and so that second round for him his
technicals were amazing then we talked
afterwards and uh you know and I didn't
want to ask him this ahead of time
because I didn't want to psych myself
out but I'm like how much have you been
sparring a lot like about a dozen times
and one of the sparring sessions was
with uh who he said it was like a 14
year old boxer but like a professional
like some world champion on track to be
yeah like some world champion 14 year
old boxer and that's who Michael had
sparred with and I I think he I he lost
but to be able to train at that level
um and you sparred with one person other
than your trainer which was also correct
I was fighting with the trainer but the
trainer's hard because
um they're so Technical and they're so
correct that
um it's different and he told me this
going into it he's like you know what I
you know I I'm able to throw punches and
stuff like that and and replicate it but
when you get someone who's like on
adrenaline and just like swinging and
just it's different so uh and then the
other sparring match it's like when you
take the pressure away it's very
technical and the other guy was awesome
but when you don't have that pressure
it's just it's different and uh like
after the first session I would stand up
be like I don't need to rest I'm good
all right well 30 seconds left oh man I
hope that but there it's it's so
different I can't I can't describe it
but but yeah after this first few hits I
knew this like
uh I needed probably a minute or two and
you that you don't have that luxury but
Michael was great and then afterwards he
came to the room and uh just wanted to
check in and it was so nice and was like
I don't say he's like apologetic but he
but he really was concerned and as I I
was with him like I want to make like I
felt so bad about hurting him I didn't
want to do that I mean he said his jaw
hurt a little better yeah yeah but still
it's like I felt bad either way like if
I lose uh I feel bad and if I hurt him
I'd feel bad so it's like he's like
either way it's a lose-lose but you know
it's a it was a really cool experience
did you talk to Michael much before the
fight
a little off and on
um
I didn't want to ask him any questions
about like his training or anything like
that so we talked but not about that I
was asking like hey man you order your
mouth Guardian hey uh what insurance are
you you get insurance for like stuff
like that yeah Graham's not like the guy
the only boxer there that was concerned
with insurance oh yeah I made sure about
the insurance I saw you were pretty uh
swagged out at the fight too man it
looked like you had some blue shorts a
blue little like half robe thing and it
all said invest yeah so not only were
you looking good you were spreading a
good message where'd you get those meat
yeah it was actually public uh so I
reached out to him they came through
like fast I was actually pretty
surprised but I reached out to them like
10 days before because I was so stressed
out and I knew from the beginning I'm
like oh I'm good get a sponsor or
something like that and I was so
stressed out about I didn't and 10 days
before I was like I have a great
relationship with public and like let me
just see if there's something they'd
even want to do and I emailed them and
they got back to me like yeah I know we
would love to we think it's a great
cause but so anyway so they ended up
sponsoring it and it was such a fast
turnaround time because so they they
said yes and then like a few days later
they sent out a contract for me to sign
and uh and then I signed it and it took
like another few days so the fight was
on the Saturday and I think we had like
a signed contract on Tuesday so they
only had oh my god wow
yeah and then I and I was worried I'm
like the things on Saturday and they
said don't worry about it the next day
they said okay we're gonna overnight
this where should we send it I kid you
not the cut everything was signed on
Tuesday by Thursday everything arrived
buy you the shoes too those are pretty
cool yes and they like went above and
beyond by the way I was actually really
surprised so they sent two pairs of
shoes
uh different colors like one was blue
and one was red white and blue they sent
several pairs of shorts several
different options for like yeah this
several different options for uh like
like uh like shirts and stuff like that
to where they sent a whole bunch of
towels that said
investpublic.com a whole bunch of water
bottles I mean they went above and
beyond I was actually really surprised
at both how quick they were how thorough
they were and how much they really cared
um and yeah so for that like I do
actually like genuinely want to say
thank you to public.com uh where of
course I know I keep plugging in but
like you could actually get a free stock
worth all the way up to a thousand
dollars if you want to support them they
they went I was actually I didn't I I
was worried that they wouldn't be able
to get it in time and I was like all
right well you know at least I tried but
they did and they were so supportive so
if you guys want to support them the
Link's down below that's such a cool
thing for company to do yeah public.com
Graham so walk us through your emotions
of that trip to Tampa in the beginning
all the way through to the end how did
you feel throughout terrible this has
been the biggest anxiety thing and the
closer I got the more anxious I get and
started impacting my work like I really
started
um the week before was the hardest
because I knew like you could count the
days you know like a week from today and
it got so bad that like any time Macy
would bring it up I don't want to talk
about it just like don't mention it yeah
I'm in the house yeah more than Jack and
Graham even told me he's like yeah I
told Macey's like if you could just not
bring it up until we're you know in
Tampa and I was like wow yeah I think I
even mentioned that to you I'm just like
I don't want to talk about it like even
any mention like hey uh so what are you
gonna how long are you in Tampa for I
don't want to talk about it like really
I because I got every time I think about
it it was like this mini uh anxiety
attack and my heart would start racing
it would take me like a minute or two to
calm down so and and it's even worse at
night when I'm trying to fall asleep but
I think about it and I'm awake how was
your sleep the night before because I'm
sure everybody like not including you
like all the fighters I'm sure they were
really nervous did you get like a normal
I did actually because I was so ready to
get it over with I was so like it's
weird but it's like this weird thing
where it's like this bell curve where
it's like Midway through him the most
nervous but the closer I get the less
nervous I got because I was so happy to
get it over with and then the day of
them like finally it's like I could get
this done with I don't have to worry
because there's so many things that went
through my mind of like what if I break
my nose what if I could hurt what if I
hurt Michael like I know what could
happen
so I let my imagination get the best of
me for sure and then and then it's all
the did I train enough did I do enough
how much is he doing I psyched myself
out I went on a subreddit and I'm like
then I read what other people said it
was really bad I would have been better
off well man I'm I know you're not
looking through the YouTube videos or
anything but uh I gotta say everybody
was really supportive in the comments of
the fight
for you yeah yeah obviously and Michael
but I literally I want to say like 99
all good yeah I read a few comments and
I saw like one of the top comments was
like it takes a lot of guts to get in
the ring with someone as crazy as
Michael uh and I don't know Michael that
much on like a personal level like that
but it seems to be that the people have
known him for a long time are like once
he once he commits to doing something he
like pours himself into it and
uh you know I'm
for me this this was not something I
poured myself into like I definitely
gave it as much as I could given every
like I didn't want to fall behind on
videos or anything like that so like I
gave it as much as I could given my
workload but for someone like Michael I
mean he'll be as dedicated as he needs
to and I I just couldn't do that plus I
mean skill wise
I mean I don't even know I don't even
know if I had done the same training as
Michael
he could just be very well better I mean
so like I I don't know I can't discredit
him for that because he was really good
A lot of people also said the were
telling me the age difference
I mean I don't know I think it depends
on the person I think it's bad yeah that
is true uh so what so he's got like five
six years on me but um younger yeah but
I don't know because uh I think training
is still a huge part but I weighed I
think it was six pounds more than him
six or seven so it's like he might uh be
younger but I also weigh a little more
but the weight isn't necessarily all
muscle I mean it's certainly there's
some some fat in there as well so that
wouldn't help besides just being like a
bigger Mass part of me worries that this
first event was so good and just like so
authentic how could you one-up it
because like the next one has to be
better yeah and I feel like it has to be
better it was a great event I had I had
such a blast the entire time too it's
awesome yeah and everyone that watched
loved it all of the clips and highlights
are like getting crazy so good on
YouTube yeah yeah so I heard so from
what I'm told the arena sold out which
is 10 000 people I heard from somebody
there that it was the first time the
year Arena had ever been sold out wow
that would be really cool if that's the
case yeah
um and then I think there's something
like 130 000 pay-per-view streams that
were confirmed
um and there's so many last minute
papers they sold a lot of merch too oh
wow yeah that's awesome so yeah they re
I don't know exactly how much was raised
for the Charities
um I probably won't know for a little
while but so walk us through your
injuries oh man oh man it sucked yeah
um well initially it was bloody nose
and uh it's it I didn't bleed that much
during but like afterwards when I got
back in the locker room that's when just
I guess it just started up then mild
concussion and some swelling around the
face the hardest part for me has been my
nose the swelling is going down you
can't see it so much inside my nose it's
so weird like if if I put my finger
right here it's like it gets cut off
because it feels like there's a balloon
inside my nose wow so it's like I could
barely breathe throughout my nose right
now because it's like the inside is a
little swollen yeah so like this part is
like three times bigger than it should
be
it's getting better though and I looked
at it in the mirror and it looks like
these two big like
bags of blood that are like filled on
you said it's weird but so anyway it's
it's that and then slight neck pain but
that's getting better and then oh the
concussion was the war that was such a
weird feeling that night there's so much
regulation back there like I didn't
realize that there had to be a boxing
commissioner uh who physically signs off
on every part of the glove process so
like yeah so we're back there and like
they have to wrap a certain way and
there's somebody there from the boxing
commission watching that like so you
don't stick anything in your groove or
something right and then after that
part's done they see it they inspect if
she's there the entire watching and she
just signs it off with a sharpie and
then they go to the next part and then
they wrap it in this and she's sitting
there watching signs it off again and
then we put our hands in the in the
glove and then there's like a tape over
the glove or something like that oh oh
there's a special tape that they wrap
around your fingers that so you could
tell like if it's been tampered like you
know sometimes they'll put them on boxes
and like if broken
they did that like around the fingers
then the glove goes on and then they do
the same thing they wrap it and they
sign off on it so like every step of the
way is signed off so do they check it
after yes yes so after the glove comes
off you lay down and they sit there
there's someone there so they take it
very seriously so they would know so if
you cheated they're like okay let's
correct yeah oh yeah but then in
addition to that they also do they take
your vitals before and then after just
so they could have a baseline of like
what you're like before and that you're
healthy enough and then afterwards they
had uh between one and two doctors check
you out afterwards to see if you have
any you know threatening injuries that
might require you because apparently
they say you're covered from this event
until you step off the premises so if
you leave and you have an inner injury
uh and you try to come back that's not
covered you're only covered while you're
in there so and then that'll be reported
while you're in the locker room yes yeah
so and then they say also that if you
have an injury and you're not sure best
to wait here and just and if if you need
our doctors at any point we're here
which you know is good they gave me this
insurance form that gives me 30 days
they say if you have any issues here's
an insurance form where you could go to
the hospital it details everything that
that occurred and this will be covered
so basically whatever I would need in
the 30 days related to this will be
covered how do you feel now like the
entire sentiment towards the boxing
match in general good and bad I've I've
not watched a single I can't bring
myself to watch that why uh it's really
hard I just can't do it because you
don't want to watch yourself get punched
you don't want to feel the Sensation
that you're feeling during the Box yeah
both both
um because it was so intense for me that
like I I can't watch that again the Bell
oh gosh Macy was Macy was making a video
on this and like I heard it in the
background like I immediately had to
leave because it's like the Bell going
like the ding ding or like whatever it
is it brought me back to that moment of
like just all the fear and anxiety and
it reminds me of like you know it sounds
like GTS it sounds like but I don't want
to like I think it's called like
Association or something like that but I
don't want to call it PTSD because I
know people have it way worse than than
that yeah and I know it's all relative
but uh but still it just it takes me
back to like that moment and the fear
and the anxiety and just I can't watch
it and then I remember from my
perspective that night and if I I just I
don't want to see it I don't want to
watch it just be because it's so fresh I
mean you know I'm sure maybe if you give
it some time yeah you know maybe
eventually you'll be curious to watch it
you'll pull it up
um but definitely just take the time
that you need there's no blush you know
yeah I just yeah I can't watch it maybe
at some point what about you jack how is
uh how's your experience watching the
fight as a as a spectator sure what was
your favorite fight obviously aside from
grams aside from grams my favorite fight
I thoroughly enjoyed Ian's fight like
that was just crazy uh and also Alex
Ernst and Ryan that was the that was the
most intense for me Haley and minks too
yeah that one was was also up there so
all the fights were great uh my
experience with the event was fantastic
I had such a fantastic time and seeing
Graham like I said walking out of the
thing and everyone's like cheering him
on and he goes and stands up there and
then seeing him land a few punches on
Michael that was so cool I knew it was
like he was gonna get a bunch of texts
but like you know as your friend like we
all had to text you like hey man yeah I
appreciate it and I was just like oh
like I was like I felt so proud that
like you know my friend my boss he's
like he's like doing this huge thing
yeah I think a big part of it also is
like seeing that that's not some that's
something that's very atypical of you
yeah you went extremely far out of your
comfort zone and that's something I
advocate for and it made me really
stoked to see you like do something
that's new maybe you don't like it maybe
you do like it but you used some weird
logic like oh you're you're 80 and
you're looking back on your life would
you be upset if you didn't do it yes you
would okay let's do it yeah that's true
and that still applies yeah so I don't
regret it and you don't regret it at all
you feel really happy about it and
everything yeah I mean obviously it's
still like you know I am disappointed I
felt like I didn't give it as much as I
should have
but uh
you know and obviously you go back and
you're like oh I should have done all
this stuff you could have recovered
after
um getting hit in the face like those
couple of times I'd never been hit like
that before so it's like it shocked me
do you think you could have recovered
though I think I
maybe but then I went on this risk
versus reward of like
if no seriously it's like Split Second
like let's just say yeah I could recover
how hurt do I want to be do I want to
risk breaking my nose
Michael I think at that point proved to
be the superior uh fighter I think in
that moment between his technique the
hits the accuracy
and I
I thought you know I don't think I could
win at that point
so it's like
maybe I could have recovered but also
that would mean that I would
probably dig a deeper grave for myself
so I don't know but that I want to say
that second fight like I don't really
remember most of it I think that that
first hit as just yeah because
everything yeah off camera I was like
Grandma I was like by the way like what
was going through your head when you
were like like you're like I'm out of my
I don't know he's like what are you
talking about he's like I don't he's
like he's like I lost and I was like he
didn't remember he said yeah and you
know I think that was just your
instincts probably I have another
question for you yeah do you think that
this boxing match will
uh will encourage you to take more risks
in the future regarding life and just
what you want to do uh I don't know I'm
not sure I mean certainly now in
comparison nothing else seems like that
scary that's really good yeah that's
really good so like anything I'd go
through like I'd set the bar so high
that it makes everything else seem like
nothing in comparison confident
uh that's yet to be seen I don't know
maybe Jack's been sending over some logo
ideas and I think we should we should
talk about it here and we should let our
audience help us what do you guys think
I I would love that yeah you sent over
some logo ideas I was asking Alex about
this
um
so I'll tell you my thoughts on this
we've had this picture of me as the uh
the logo of the iced coffee hour since
the very beginning happy two years by
the way yep in two years since we
started the iced coffee hour yeah I
guess yeah so we've had that since the
very beginning at first it was me with a
tattoo that said like iced coffee hour
over my eye
um we changed it to the more
professional one but I think at this
point we want to do a more like
Universal branding and Jack and I took
pictures together and they turned out
horrible terrible yeah we've done it
twice yeah I took the pictures guys
we also took version one oh the one of
you guys right now yeah you should yeah
okay I'll have to find it it's really
fast it looks like wearable it looks
like a couple we look like a couple yeah
you look like a married couple yeah
I remember I put it up as the profile
photo for like I think it was for one
podcast episode and it was up for like
three hours and I just get a text from
Graham like take it back he's like just
switch it back man this is really bad oh
yeah so I'll tell you I told Alex my I
agree that there should be a universal
logo throughout everything to keep the
consistency I guess my biggest concern
is um
brand like awareness or I guess that
that's my biggest I felt like with
because the iced coffee hour
doesn't mention any more like with
graham staff enter with Graham and Jack
and so for Branding I was I feel like my
face helps with that since it's not
mentioned anywhere else like the H3
podcast it mentions H3 like the grand
podcast the H3 podcast uh the full send
podcast it mentions like full send the
iced coffee hour is so obscure
that I worry do people even know I'm
associated with it uh and will that help
gather more views because I look at this
as like what is going to reach the
biggest audience as fast as possible and
part of me feels like my face helps with
that
but I also agree at the same point that
there does need to be something
Universal that looks professional that
could be used everywhere I think it
would be good if it could be its own
entity a little bit more than like
trying to
like harp on the success of grams which
obviously we've totally used and it's
been really successful for us but I also
think it would be good because for like
sponsors for other stuff it's good to
look have like a professional clean logo
and everything and like you said for
Branding too I think it's it's probably
better yeah I don't my thing is another
like it's like Graham's fifth channels
Graham six Channel or something I get
that I get that one I mean I like it
like the ice coffee or if you have its
own logo and everything it would have a
different level of importance
which I think would be good for the
brand I also mentioned that we were
talking that Graham's also in like a lot
of the the thumbnails anyway yeah yes
that's probably what people would see
that's what that's what I thought
um
so I'm open to it I didn't like the ones
we'll put them up on screen I didn't
like the ich because that to me it's
just like itch I see or ick yeah for
people who are into aquariums ick is
Like A Parasite I had to see ick yeah I
think you're also maybe placing a little
bit too much significance on the profile
photo like a lot of people I was looking
around have terrible profile photos and
as long as it's like you can see who it
is and ideally it looks clean then I
think that's a good thing and I think
having a logo up there would be good I
don't know that's I just think it would
be fun if we make a poll
and we could put it in the description
and uh we just let people see what they
like I would like that you know what I
like with nelx is it's just like the
full send podcast black background I
think it would look cool just like a
black background iced coffee hour and
that's too big too big really when I was
doing uh iced coffee or Clips back when
I first started I was trying to I didn't
want to use your face because I wanted
people to be able to differentiate
between the clips Channel and the iced
coffee our Channel and I think I went
with Ich right isn't it just like a like
it looks like a coffee or something and
because it looks so tiny you're like
yeah but you know what would be fun that
we could do is maybe offer like a
certain amount people could submit their
own ideas so here's what I'm thinking I
think 250 and a FaceTime call with all
three of us so you could ask us whatever
you want or we could talk or network or
whatever and maybe it'll lead to other
opportunities in the future limited to
two hours max the face
yeah yeah but yeah just send over your
designs and we'll take when when should
be the deadline seven days from now a
week from yeah a week from when this is
posted so whenever this video is up
seven days after seven days I'm gonna
look at them all so after seven days
don't set anymore because I'm not yeah
and again it should not say ich looks
like ick oh one more thing I want to
talk about
the market oh my gosh everybody we're so
happy that you sold Robinhood and the
next day it was up 30 you sold and then
hours later
I know yeah decides to take a stake in
Robin Hood yeah oh my God how does that
make you feel man look man have I not
been telling you this for months
I I know it's hard to to reorient your
brain especially after that I'm not a
superstitious man I don't think because
I bought Robin Hood At tanked and I
don't think that it went up because I
sold I think that it's just completely
coincidence just coincidence the most
coincidental thing that could have ever
happened the fact that we make an
episode we almost did and one we boasted
at 1 pm 110. there's like green candle
it goes up like 11 could you do us all a
favor if you buy everything if you buy
can you just tell me so I could sell
give us a 24-hour notice I if you need
disclosures like like this like the
Senate like 24 hours later you have to
disclose your own
that's funny it honestly blows my mind
that actually happened I still like I
don't even want to think about it
because it just it's too much for my
little brain to process the fact that
that actually happened I sold and then
it just but it is true the moment you
bought it dipped yeah it did so both
ways so how but we what if we put it to
the test Jack's just buy like a hundred
dollars I'm done individual stocks I'm
done how about this no but if we but
because I would tell like you to buy
something that maybe just as a test no
but maybe just as like a test but then I
think we're gonna jinx it if you do
something purposely it's not gonna work
it's never what you want it's only when
you seriously making a mess but when
it's actually like what are you buying
right now sizable chunk of change what
am I buying right now well he said he's
done with it I know you know indexes and
stuff like that oh they're Doom next
that's what I'm about to say I've always
but it's not like I'm just now buying it
hold on are you actually done with
individual stocks pretty much yeah wow
yeah you got burned you learned or
earned you learned really yeah so I'm
not like I don't think it's a terrible
idea and it's like sure if there are
companies I still have apple right okay
Apple's a great company I have Intel
I've held I've held on to Intel for a
super long time I have some like select
companies that I've held on for a while
but I'm not going out buying like the
more speculative plays the fintech
companies with these crazy valuations
I'm just yeah very small percent of my
portfolio is individual stuff when did
you start buying index funds uh I
bought my first Index Fund probably not
first but like seriously buying index
yeah okay so I put a thousand dollars in
spy I think or XLF or something like
that so I'm like
group right where they gather all the
stocks together uh and that was probably
back in like 2015. okay what about uh
did you buy in November of 2021
probably yeah yeah it makes sense makes
sense yeah
yeah anyway see now I'm worried that
like you're buying index funds like
that's the start of the recession
yeah that's the story what happens when
I short a stock if I buy stuff you know
it's the same thing it's not by now no I
think that'd be that would be but the
thing is if you're doing it as an
experiment it's not gonna work yeah
it's going to be like a seriously change
form yeah yeah it has to really believe
Jack believes it that's what we need
yeah just let us know before you okay do
anything deal all right so with that
said you guys thank you so much for
watching uh again you could send to Alex
your submissions for the iced coffee
hour logos also big thank you uh to all
of you guys who subscribe hit the
notification Bell who've watched the
Creator Clash fight really appreciate it
and uh anything else guys you gotta
thank the people that made the drive
just to see you oh that's true because
there were a few fans that were like I
only came here to see Graham and you
know what else you know what we have to
talk about too yeah you know okay go
ahead we met last note yeah for the
first time dgb and now you got to put a
picture yeah yeah put a picture here uh
he has been the guy from the very
beginning who's been like helping us
with title thumbnails with rankings
we've mentioned multiple times here on
the podcast you go to his channel and
he's clipped out the parts where we've
talked uh about him and uh I have to say
so nice so smart really appreciated that
and it's good to like finally meet some
of the people yeah when you talk online
for such a long time it's uh it's cool
to like finally meet the person behind
the comment
um so I that really means a lot so and
for everyone who made the drive out or
fruit watched it like that seriously
means a lot so and I wish I could just
meet everybody uh maybe we'd coordinate
something like that at some point but uh
really means a lot we do another meet
and greet like Dave Ramsey just walk up
on stage picture leave
anyway guys thank you I really
appreciate it and subscribe until next
time
great all right good